doctors are warning parents of RSV it is
a respiratory virus that infects the
lungs and breathing passages as 8 news
now reporter Joshua pagera explains RSV
cases have more than doubled in several
States including ours placing a strain
at area hospitals
[Music]
Brady sahakyan is new to parenting
through everything that he comes in
contact with is clean uh try and stay
away from you know random strangers his
two-year-old son has avoided a severe
cold so far but he's already thinking of
his son's preschool when he's old enough
to enroll a clean environment you know
no kids running around with runny noses
that kind of thing Dr Michael tenby of
Centennial Pediatrics says RSV
infections are high and arriving earlier
in the year we saw a lot of it in
October and it's continuing full force
now even though it's earlier in the year
and it's not so cold yet RSV symptoms
are similar to a cold but more severe
infants experience wheezing CDC data
shows each year 58 000 children under
the age of five are hospitalized with
RSV it can lead to severe bronchitis or
pneumonia for those in that age bracket
here at Hillandale they've been lucky
that kids have not been sick with RSV or
any type of cold-like symptoms that's
because the director says they
prioritize cleanliness hand washing is
number one they wipe down counters and
they also have hand sanitizers handy as
a backup plan Tammy Gates of Hillandale
Child Development Center says staff pay
attention to kids when they seem to be
getting sick because of the small groups
they have time to clean they have time
to sanitize they have time to follow
through on hand washing and that matters
that matters a lot day cares recommend
if your child isn't feeling good keep
them home so they don't affect other
kids Joshua figuero eight news now